[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin Koch vor etwa einem Jahr haben
wir beschlossen einen kleinen Wohnwagen
in einem food Truck umzubauen wir
wollten etwas Neues finden eine
Extra-Motivation diesen Job zu machen
und dann haben wir beschlossen es für
die Kunden zu tun sie wollen nicht mehr
in Restaurants so eingeschränkt sie
wollen lieber mit Menschen kommunizieren
und etwas besonderes Essen auch wenn sie
dafür stehen müssen
in den letzten Monaten haben sich in
unserem Land und im Ausland die
Veranstaltungen zum Thema street food
vervielfacht ziel ist es den Trend der
Zeit des street food vorzustellen und
weiter zu entwickeln und die Leute haben
immer mit großer Begeisterung und
Neugierde darauf reagiert
[Musik]
wir haben Festivals besucht vor allem in
Italien wir haben Festivals in der
Schweiz besucht wir haben gesehen was
die Leute mögen die Art von Essen mit
einem guten Geruch einem guten Geschmack
wir haben uns angeschaut wie die
Fahrzeuge aufgebaut sind welche Farben
verwendet werden und dann haben wir
angefangen alles zu planen
[Musik]
wo ist die Sekunde viele Menschen denken
fälschlicherweise dass man damit viel
Geld verdienen kann ich denke es ist
eher ein Lebensstil und das Ziel die
Vita geht die Straße die Leute und man
lernt das wahre Leben in unserer Gegend
kennen LaVita Vera
[Musik]
das ist eine gesellschaftliche Bewegung
immer mehr Menschen in unserem Land
wollen sich selbstständig machen sie
sind nicht mehr zufrieden mit ihrer
Arbeit in einem Unternehmen wie in einem
Restaurant weil es dort einen oder
mehrere Manager gibt nun werden Sie ihr
eigener Manager Sie tätigen ihre eigenen
Investitionen sie gehen ihre eigenen
Risiken ein aber ihre Erfolge sind ganz
allein ihre Sache
sie bringen ihre Leidenschaft mit den
Wunsch ihre Kochkünste zu zeigen
ein Beispiel Küchen in Lieferwagen und
Ständen tauchen auf sogar auf unseren
Straßen diese Art von Tätigkeit ist
verlockend für diejenigen die sich in
diesem Sektor betätigen wollen die
Anfangsinvestitionen beträgt keine
50.000 Euro das ist nichts im Vergleich
zu den Kosten und den bürokratischen
Anforderungen für einen
Restaurantbetrieb es handelt sich hier
um eine Art von Aktivität die noch ein
bisschen
deren Trends sind ich hoffe dass
vielleicht auf kantonaler und kommunaler
Ebene ein paar Plätze organisiert werden
wo alle foodtrucks geparkt werden können
und wir auch den Rest des Jahres
arbeiten können
[Musik]
im Moment vorerst werden wir weiterhin
auf Messen Veranstaltungen Konzerten
sein und allem was im Sommer so
stattfindet die schwierigen Zeiten
kommen im Winter denn wir hatten gehofft
einen festen Standort zu finden der uns
ein regelmäßiges Einkommen garantiert
die Gemeinden die Bürokratie es gibt
Fristen es dauert sehr lange bis man
eine Antwort bekommt die fast nie
positiv ist
bis vor zehn Jahren hatten die Gemeinde
nur mit Gastronomen zu tun die
miteinander konkurrierten jetzt ist
deine neue Art von Fachleuten
aufgetaucht die eine ganz andere
Struktur haben
und sie müssen über die Pacht
entscheiden einige Gemeinden haben Angst
Fehler zu machen und sind deshalb etwas
zurückhaltend bei der Erteilung von
Lizenzen
auch wenn das Phänomen noch nicht weit
verbreitet ist werden wir in der übrigen
Schweiz mit diesen neuen Aktivitäten
konfrontiert die fast immer von dem
Berufsverbänden der Restaurants bekämpft
werden die sie als unlautere
Wettbewerber betrachten
Genf und Freiburg haben damit begonnen
öffentliche Flächen für Straßenküchen
zur Verfügung zu stellen und einige
Kantone sind bereits dabei sie
gesetzlich zu regeln
street food bietet die Möglichkeit
ethnische oder regionale Produkte zu
essen ohne viel Geld auszugeben vor
allem für junge Leute und es ist
offensichtlich dass sich Angebote und
Nachfrage weiter vervielfachen werden
street food sollte leicht zu essen sein
oder
also schneiden wir es sehen Sie wie
einfach sie schneiden können man braucht
keine Gabeln und Messer
nun ja in meinem food Truck wäre ich
etwas eleganter und würde sie auf einem
kleinen Teller servieren
das erste street food in der Geschichte
geht auf die Ägypter zurück
in Alexandria kamen die Boote mit den
Fischern an und der Fisch wurde an Ort
und Stelle gebraten und an die Fischer
selbst verkauft von dort aus ging es
nach Griechenland und zu den Römern
streetfood hat auch seine Liebhaber sie
treffen sich bei den Kochkursen von
Viviana lapetosa
reist gerne um die authentische und
populäre Küche zu entdecken
ihre Recherchen führen uns zu den
Ursprüngen und der möglichen
Weiterentwicklung dieses Phänomens wie
nennt man das
[Musik]
also ich zeige Ihnen zwei verschiedene
Arten die klassische mit Fleischsauce
hier ist sie eine Mahlzeit für sich das
geht auf die Antike zurück es sieht aus
wie ein Gericht aus Essensresten
tatsächlich wurde es bei den
Jagdgesellschaften der adligen serviert
damit sie eine gekochte Mahlzeit
genießen konnten diese reißbällchen mit
gebratenen Auberginen stammen aus
Catania und sind nach normannischer Art
zubereitet jeder Aspekt des street food
ist sehr spezifisch das heißt ich gehe
dorthin weil ich z.B ein ganz bestimmtes
Sandwich essen möchte egal ob es an
einem Marktstand angeboten wird oder
eben an einem Lastwagen sie machen dort
in der Regel nur ein paar wenige
Gerichte aber die machen sie dann
richtig gut wenn du in Palermo adancini
frittierst dann machst du das die ganze
Zeit und dann werden deine Arancini
wahrscheinlich auch die Besten sein weil
du die Übung hast und bei der
Zubereitung einfach keine Fehler mehr
machst
ich nehme sie jetzt mit nach Asien
wir sind in Thailand
wie erkennt man Straßen essen wenn man
keine Ahnung davon hat du kommst in ein
Land und bist völlig ahnungslos du musst
verstehen wie die Märkte funktionieren
was die Verkäufer verkaufen was du
kaufen musst
aber wenn du dieses Geräusch hörst
kannst du sagen dass das Papaya Salat
ist
denn es geht nur ums schlagen und
mischen
[Musik]
und du kannst den Verkäufer sagen nicht
zu scharf aber ihr Schaf ist unser sehr
scharf
das interessante an street food ist dass
man das Essen der ganzen Welt auf
Knopfdruck bekommt
im Vergleich zu früher ist das glaube
ich die größte Veränderung und das was
wir am liebsten mögen es gibt auch Leute
die lokale Gerichte kochen aber sie auf
der Straße servieren und das mögen die
Leute auch
ich stelle mir einen Polenta stand vor
das könnte erfolgreich sein oder einen
suppenstand im Winter wo man hingeht
in den Großstädten gibt es sowas oft und
ich glaube das ist in unserem Land auf
einer viel breiteren Ebene ankommen wird
schon sagten die jungen Leute sind die
größten Kunden von streetfood
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sagen wir ich habe das wenige Geld dass
ich hatte verwendet ich hätte nicht
ausgereicht um die Stühle für ein
Restaurant zu kaufen und dann habe ich
etwas Hilfe von meiner Familie bekommen
die mir den Staat ermöglicht hat
ein Mietvertrag abgeschlossen der mir
geholfen hat das zu kaufen was heute
mein Zuhause und mein Arbeitsplatz ist
sozusagen
das war meine Freundin die auf die Idee
mit dem Lkw kam
eines Tages als sie sah dass ich ein
wenig verloren war teilte sie mir ihre
Idee mit nicht sofort Annahme aber nach
einer Weile wurde mir klar das ist das
Richtige zur richtigen Zeit sein könnte
[Musik]
Karriere ist außergewöhnlich er
arbeitete in großem Restaurants in ganz
Europa darunter eines der besten der
Welt des drei Sterne mit Restaurant
Geranium in Kopenhagen
heute finden wir ihn auf den Märkten von
Locarno Lugano und Bellinzona mit
persönlichen Gerichten und im Gegentrend
als ich es gegründet habe war die erste
Frage was willst du machen und ich sagte
nur nicht ich möchte das Menü jede Woche
ändern er sagte zu mir du bist verrückt
es ist unmöglich niemand macht das und
wenn ich sowas höre dann spornt mich das
an für mich beginnt mein Menü am
Donnerstag hier in Lugano und dauert
vier Tage am zweiten Tag plane ich schon
die nächste Woche denn es gibt viele
Dinge die ich im Laufe der Jahre gelernt
habe und die mich zu dem Koch gemacht
haben der ich jetzt bin und ich
unbedingt so oft wie möglich umsetzen
will
seine Herausforderung besteht darin sich
durch die Einzigartigkeit der Gerichte
durch die Techniken und die Erfahrung
der Gourmetküche hervorzuheben die für
alle erschwinglich ist während er
weiterhin den Job macht den er liebt
mir das schöne an meinem food Truck ist
dass ich um 4:30 Uhr bis 5 Uhr morgens
aufwachen und bis 7:30 Uhr arbeiten kann
und meine Sachen zu produzieren in
meinem Restaurant kann man das nicht sei
denn man wohnt darüber man kann nicht um
5 Uhr morgens hingehen und einfach zu
arbeiten für mich ist das wichtig weil
ich so mein Privatleben mit meiner
Arbeit vereinbaren kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in Palermo der italienischen Hauptstadt
des streetfood treffen wir uns erneut
mit Viviana lapetosa
der Geschmack von Knorpel und kalbsfett
ist sehr
delikato erwarten Sie keinen starken
Geschmack
meiner Meinung nach schmeckt es wie
Hühnerhaut
hier in Palermo ist das streetfood zu
einer Touristenattraktion geworden es
gibt spezialisierte Führer die
Spaziergänge über die Märkte und die
Hauptplätze des historischen Zentrums
organisieren und die Gelegenheit bieten
die Spezialitäten der besten
Frittenbuden und Straßenstände zu
probieren und die Stadt so zu erleben
wie es die Einwohner Palermos jeden Tag
tun
[Musik]
das straßenessen ist eine der Grundlagen
der Kultur von Palermo bei Streety sagen
wir immer dass ein pernelle Sandwich die
Geschichte Palermos erzählt
genauso wie die Kathedrale die Kirche la
martorama oder der katrocanti
besuchen und das Essen nicht probieren
ist es als wären sie nie in Palermo
gewesen
[Musik]
bist du der Beste mezaro in Palermo oder
auf der ganzen Welt auf der ganzen Welt
denn das Milz Sandwich gibt es nur ein
Palermo man kann es nirgendwo anders auf
der Welt finden also ich will nicht
arrogant sein und angeben aber das wird
nirgendwo anders gemacht als ein paar
lernen also bin ich der beste auf der
ganzen Welt
das ist die berühmteste Spezialität von
Palermo sie repräsentiert Palermo viel
mehr als das Opernhaus
Graz
[Musik]
wenn man das Können eines sizilianischen
Kochs genau beobachtet ist das mehr wert
als 1000 Kochbücher wir machen 13 Pfund
pro Tag wie viele Reisbällchen sind das
eine Menge
[Musik]
das straßenessen im Palermo scheint im
Ansturm der großen Ketten zu trotzen die
berühmtesten amerikanischen Ketten haben
es versucht aber sie hatten immer nur
die Teenager im Auge also hält das
street food dagegen schon seit 2600
Jahren und wir hoffen dass es noch lange
dagegenhalten wird
was sie da haben ist eine Art Ofen das
ist ein Gasofen und dann habe ich die
Pfanne in der ich alles erhitze komme
und sie mal
fantastisch ein bisschen Öl das ist
typisch für Palermo er ist 100 Jahre alt
er ist schone ist sehr weich
[Musik]
wann werden die gebacken morgens
gebacken ich kaufe dies sind schon alle
in Palermo die sind schone machen kaufen
Sie wie viele machen Sie am Tag 100 pro
Tag ein Gast der hierher nach Palermo
kommt und sie probieren will hat ein
Problem denn er wird sie immer essen
wollen macht es süchtig ja Sommer oder
Winter du bist immer hier das ist Arbeit
das ist das Brot meines Sohnes
das ist der typische Sven schon von
Palermo meine Damen und Herren
ist so süß sie ist gehackt und ja sie
ist süßer als normal
sehr gut
[Musik]
ich komme schon zum xten Mal nach
Palermo um das authentischste streetfood
zu finden Palermo ist eine Küche unter
freiem Himmel es gibt Rauch Geschrei
Leute die Kochen Menschen die essen
jedes Gericht erzählt von der
Vergangenheit von den Arabern ein Stück
Brot mit Sesam darauf erzählt von der
arabischen Herrschaft und Palermo hat
das geschafft sich in alles einzufügen
nicht wahr im Vergleich zu anderen
Völkern haben die ganzen Einflüsse hier
die Kulturbereich hat
das sind doch wenn ich mich nicht irre
die Glocke dieses Croque nennt man
raskia Tura mit panela Kartoffeln und
roten Zwiebeln wird das alles
miteinander vermischt
[Musik]
ja es ist mehr Panella als Kartoffel
weil es mit denen gemacht wird was in
der Pfanne für die panela übrig bleibt
früher war es ein arme Leute essen
und heute heute ist es für alle jeder
mag das wie viel Öl verwenden Sie am Tag
3,4 bis 3,7 Gallonen da muss man es ja
oft wechseln jeden Tag
ich probiere zuerst mal ich glaube ihre
sind die leckersten oder
[Musik]
sehr gut
was ist das fleischbrötchen mit
Paniermehl Semmelbrösel Schinken Käse
Rosinen Salz und Pfeffer
[Musik]
und es heißt Essen und Trinken warum
essen und trinken weil die Zwiebel
ziemlich stark ist und wenn man sie
probiert muss man trinken du musst
trinken
wie kommt es dass man in der
sizilianischen Küche hauptsächlich Fisch
erwartet obwohl es so viel Fleisch gibt
Fleischfresser sind
Kannibalen aber wir kochen unser Fleisch
hol mir ein Tablet
[Musik]
ich war 8 Jahre alt als ich mit diesem
Job anfing
doch mit acht Jahren bin ich zur Schule
gegangen und habe gearbeitet
ich habe geheiratet ich habe eine Frau
ich habe Kinder jetzt bin ich Großvater
und ich bin immer noch hier hat sich nie
jemand über den Rauch beschwert
sich denn nur die Stadtverwaltung tut
das
wollen nicht dass wir auf der Straße
kochen aber da das Essen auf der Straße
beginnt sollte es auch draußen sterben
[Musik]
ein Muss für Liebhaber des abendlichen
streetfood ist die historische und sehr
überfüllte ruggeria
auch wenn sie schon immer geduldet
wurden sind alle diese Straßenküchen
nicht wirklich zugelassen
gedünsteter Oktopus du bist also ein ein
wie lange werden die gedünstet die sind
ja winzig 10 Minuten aber mit dieser
Pfanne das ist der traditionelle Topf
aus Palermo er hat keinen Boden
und damit kocht es sich noch besser
ist der schon geschlagen nein das machen
wir nicht ihr schlagt ihn nicht in
Apulien schon wir schlagen andere Dinge
aber nicht den Tintenfisch nein wie
viele schmoren sie am Tag am Abend 33
Pfund genau
die jungen Leute interessieren sich
nicht für diese traditionelle Arbeit es
ist eines der alten Handwerker das
niemand mehr machen will weil es ihnen
peinlich wäre gedünsteten Tintenfisch zu
verkaufen sie suchen sich lieber einen
Bürojob oder sitzen auf einem Liegestuhl
aber die Familien können mit dieser
Arbeit ihren Lebensunterhalt verdienen
das sind sie Erdbeeren
[Musik]
salva der Oktopus poet
wie viel verlangen sie für ein solches
Gericht 5 Euro das ist wirklich nicht so
viel 5 Euro für den Oktopus egal wie
groß das hängt von seinem Gewicht ab
aber zuerst schaue ich mir die Leute an
und wenn sie mir so sympathisch sind
auf diesem Platz ist das wie in einem
Theater man kommt hierher wegen der
typischen und preiswerten Speisen dem
gedünsteten Tintenfisch dem gegrillten
den gefüllten Sardinen aber vor allem
weil das sizilianische straßenessen
jeden fesselt fasziniert und erobert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das Essen auf der Straße ist eine so
angenehme und köstliche Erfahrung dass
einige Spezialitäten heute auch in den
Restaurants zu finden sind
es ist schön zu sehen wie die
parlamentarische Street food-tradition
die Restaurants in Palermo selbst
erreicht und dann sogar ins Ausland
exportiert wird
das gibt denjenigen die nicht wie die
parlamentaner durch die Märkte und
Straßen der Stadt ziehen können die
Möglichkeit street food in einem
klassischen Rahmen wie in einem
Restaurant zu genießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
London eine dynamische Stadt die in
vielen Bereichen eine Art Trendsetter
ist hierhin folgen wir Viviana labettosa
der Köchin die unterwegs ist um
herauszufinden was in den food Trucks
und an den Ständen der englischen
Metropole passiert
[Musik]
was sollen wir heute probieren ihr
Lieblingsessen ich würde den Couscous
probieren eigentlich habe ich ihn schon
probiert das ist mit Huhn das ist mit
Paprika
sehen Sie sie verwenden frische Zutaten
an den asiatischen Ständen sind oft
Asiaten und es gibt Ihnen eine
Vorstellung davon wie beliebt sie sind
denn es gibt Touristen die sie probieren
aber auch Einheimische verschiedener
Nationalitäten oder jedenfalls aus
dieser Gegend
nehmen sie manchmal auch was mit ins
Büro
auf keinen Fall wenn es nicht gerade
regnet oder überschwemmt ist haben wir
eine Stunde Pause in der man spazieren
geht und im Freien ist
mit ins Büro nehmen und die Jungs sind
normalerweise gut ausgerüstet um es
einzupacken
London hat ein abwechslungsreiches
gastronomisches Angebot voller
Überraschung unter den Straßenständen
erwarte ich hauptsächlich asiatische und
multi-ethnische Spezialitäten aber es
gibt auch noch Platz für traditionelle
Rezepte die unserem europäischen Raum
viel näher sind wie zum Beispiel die
Tati flat
mein Rezept ist ein wenig geheim aber
sagen wir wir haben gekochte Kartoffeln
karamellisierte und sortierte Zwiebeln
eine Geschenke
das ganze wird mit Creme double
[Musik]
eines Abends machte ich
papierreis-rollen mit meinem Mann und
wir packten ein paar Zutaten dazu es sei
sofort nach Spaß aus und war
gleichzeitig eine gesunde und
ausgewogene Mahlzeit
sie machen Spaß man ist sie mit den
Händen wir sprachen 9 Monate lang
darüber
und irgendwann kündigte ich dann bei
PepsiCo wo ich einen schönen und
wichtigen Job hatte ich war leitende
Produktmanagerin das ist also eine große
Herausforderung für uns
es war ein großes Risiko alles
aufzugeben aber das ist mein neues Leben
[Musik]
auf der anderen Seite kann man in London
alles finden sogar eine Variation der
klassischen Diosa gebratene japanische
Teigtaschen die von Köchen zubereitet
werden die noch nie in Japan waren
trotzdem sind ihre giosa äußerst beliebt
es ist gut aber ich hätte keine
Mayonnaise genommen
[Musik]
das streetfood hat sich hier parallel
zur Krise entwickelt ein anspruchsvolles
kosmopolitisches Publikum und viele
dynamische Menschen die in diesem
Bereich einen fruchtbaren Boden gefunden
haben der offen ist für kulinarische
Überraschung
[Musik]
hallo zusammen darf ich einmal
überprüfen ob du die Hygiene und
Sicherheitsvorschriften einhältst ja
klar
kannst du mir die Dokumente geben die
das bescheinigen
sie liegen dort
ja das ist gut
wo ist das Waschbecken
[Applaus]
vielen Dank
wo ist der Feuerlöscher
weiter ich danke Ihnen vielmals
es ist sehr wichtig dass die Hygiene und
Sicherheitsvorschriften für streetfood
genauso gelten wie für Restaurants für
überprüfen rund 12 Dokumente das geht
von der Anmeldung der angewandten
Methoden bis zu den
sicherheitsverpflichtungen
überprüfen ob sie in Ordnung sind damit
alles so ist wie es sein sollte jeder
wird jede Woche kontrolliert sie müssen
die Küchen ja immer wieder auf und
abbauen und jeder der hier herkommt und
seine Produkte anzubieten muss verstehen
dass wir in Gruppenarbeiten das wenn wir
heute hier in der Morgen Street sind es
auch andere Märkte wie diesen in London
gibt und wenn irgendwo etwas schief geht
sind wir alle involviert wird
trotz des Anscheins ist hier alles sehr
gut organisiert dieser Markt entstand
vor sieben Jahren und findet nur an den
Wochenenden statt aber er hat einen
Viertel in Südosten Londons wiederbelebt
und ist sehr beliebt bei Menschen die
gerne ungewöhnliches Essen ausprobieren
wir haben jedes Wochenende 10.000
Besucher aber in den ersten beiden
Jahren nichts mehr Straßenküchen als
Kunden
das Geheimnis liegt darin Bereiche zu
nutzen in die die Menschen normalerweise
nicht gehen würden und diesen Orten
neues Leben einzuhauchen
heute pulsiert diese Gegend mit vielen
Geschäften und Unternehmen wir waren die
ersten aber heute gibt es kneipenbars
Restaurants und Geschäfte die dank der
Energie die von diesem Ort ausging
hierher kam hallo wenn es Ihnen nichts
ausmacht würde ich gerne eine
hygieneinspektion durchführen wie ist
das für einen Koch auf der Straße zu
arbeiten
das ist ganz anders im Winter bei -8
Grad ist es wirklich kalt und man hat
nicht den Komfort und die Wärme eines
richtigen Küchenherdes was angenehm ist
ich vermisse die richtige Küche ein
bisschen mit zehn Köchen um mich herum
und so
bin ich verantwortlich hier arbeite ich
mit meiner Frau zusammen und das gefällt
uns
nach meinem Abschluss in
Wirtschaftswissenschaften habe ich in
einer Bank in der Stadt gearbeitet ich
hatte Glück dass ich diese Stelle fand
denn es gab nicht allzu viele
Jobangebote
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen dass mir die
Arbeit in der Bank nicht gefiel sie war
nichts für mich es war nicht das was ich
machen wollte aber ich sah immer wieder
diese netten Jungs die mit Ihrem Ofen
auf die Straße kamen und eines Tages sah
ich einen von ihnen der in einer Stunde
300 Mahlzeiten verkaufte schaute mir
seine Speisekarte an und sagte mir
verdammt für dieser Typ verdient eine
Menge Geld wenn wir in der Bank nicht so
viel verdienen also habe ich gekündigt
und angefangen Tee zu verkaufen und
dabei viel gelernt vor allem was man
nicht tun sollte heute organisiere und
leite ich verschiedene Märkte wie diesen
in London und ich möchte nichts anderes
machen denn wir sind wie eine große
Familie
[Musik]
in London sind der Wettbewerb und die
Auswahl sehr groß aber einige Verkäufer
haben eine Lösung gefunden die den
Standard für Genehmigung setzt und für
die Suche nach privilegierten Gebieten
wie diesen im Finanzviertel Kamera
sie haben sich in einer Vereinigung
zusammengeschlossen wie zum Beispiel der
körpergruppe die täglich viele Märkte in
der Stadt veranstaltet und ihre
Mitglieder nach der Qualität ihres
Angebots auswählt
wir präsentieren uns alle zusammen als
Gruppe nicht als einzelne Anbieter
die Körper wirkt für uns macht uns
bekannt
in vor allem schafft sie es uns an
diesen unglaublichen Orten zu platzieren
es wäre unmöglich allein einen solchen
Ort im Zentrum von London zu finden
ein indisches Sandwich weit weg von
Indien das von der Zeitschrift Timeout
als eines der besten in London
bezeichnet wurde
wir haben unabhängig angefangen aber es
war unser Ziel Teil von körb zu werden
weil sie sehr hohe Qualitätsstandards
für street food haben
wir überzeugten sie davon uns in die
Gruppe aufzunehmen nachdem Sie unsere
Gerichte probiert hatten wir brachten
sie zu den Managern einiger ihrer Märkte
erklärten unsere Philosophie unsere
Marke und wer wir sind
und nach einem Monat wurden wir
aufgenommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sprechen Sie griechisch na klar und sie
nur ein paar Worte
Barak hallo Eva Risto
der aus den USA stammen des Spiros
bekannt als the grilling Greek ist bei
den Fans von Souvlaki Moussaka Gyros und
anderen griechischen Spezialitäten sehr
beliebt jeden Tag ist der mit seinem
Lieferwagen auf den Märkten der
körpergruppe unterwegs und hat auch
einen kleinen Stand auf dem überfüllten
multi-ethnischen Markt von Kempten town
[Musik]
viele Leute kommen aus der ganzen Welt
hierher um unser Modell zu kopieren in
London konnte sich das streetfood
relativ frei entwickeln also wollen sie
das Modell nachahmen das ist eine
wunderbare Sache
ich habe als Koch in New York angefangen
habe in vielen Restaurants und
Privatclubs gearbeitet
dann habe ich meine Frau kennengelernt
und wir sind nach London gezogen
ja habe ich sechs Monate lang im Hotel
Ritz gearbeitet
dann in der Küche des rollerhaus
für große Wirtschaftsmanager da fing ich
an meinen Job und erträglich zu finden
ich habe ihn nur wegen des Geldes
gemacht und nicht aus Freude am Kochen
also beschloss ich etwas anderes zu
machen ich wusste nicht mal dass es
street food geht
ich habe recherchiert und herausgefunden
dass es hier niemanden gibt der
griechische street food macht
das Rezept für das Tzatziki stammt von
meiner Mama
Gurken
knoblauchsalzessig und Fenchel Pollen
es ist als wäre man in Athen wirklich
einige Griechen haben mir gesagt es sei
besser als in Athen ich habe vielen Dank
gesagt das ist das beste aller
Komplimente dafür mache ich das
nächster Halt ist es mittelfields Markt
wo jeden Tag hunderte von Menschen bei
jedem Wetter Schlange stehen um ein
leckeres Mittagessen aus einer großen
Auswahl zu bekommen
[Musik]
das ist eine parlamentarische arancina
in London
herzlichen Glückwunsch es scheint als
wäre die Londoner Mittagspause
gleichbedeutend mit street food aber auf
der Suche nach Qualität
für 6 7 Pfund kann man in jeder andere
Pizzeria gehen sich an den Tisch setzen
und Pizza essen hier nimmt man sie mit
oder man faltet sie meistens sind das
Italiener oder sie essen sie im Stehen
und sowas zu tun bedeutet dass Sie unser
Produkt wirklich zu schätzen wissen
Silvestro moorlando ist 27 Jahre alt er
kommt aus Pescara und hat sich sofort
einen Namen gemacht mit seinen Pizzen
die er in zwei umgebauten Lieferwagen im
echten Holzöfen macht und er bereitet
schon einen dritten vor aber sein
Erfolgsrezept sind vor allem die Zutaten
glücklicherweise können wir all unsere
hochwertigen Produkte aus Italien
beziehen auch das Holz es kommt aus
formisano in der Nähe von Neapel hier
kaufen wir nur das Basilikum da ist in
Italien jetzt sehr heiß ist wir hatten
jemanden der es aus Italien mit brachte
aber es wurde ganz schwarz und wir
konnten es nicht verwenden also
beschlossen wir es hier in England zu
kaufen
da viele Kunden im Finanzbereich
Arbeiten kam es vor dass die Besten
Street food-konzepte zu einer Art
Startup wurden die Aufmerksamkeit
potentieller Investoren auf sich zog
nach drei oder vier Monaten hier ins
battlefields bekamen wir einige wirklich
tolle Angebote von Investoren ich habe
immer versucht sie abzulehnen weil ich
gerne langsam wachsen möchte um die
Qualität unserer Produkte zu erhalten
etwas das ein großes Unternehmen nicht
tun würde die packen alles mögliche auf
ihre Pizzen
[Musik]
spektakulär wirklich gut
da ist der süße Kürbis die Schärfe der
salzige Käse es gibt eine der fast
fertig ist mit sardischem Pecorino
erst so alt wie mein Vater ein bisschen
alt
er ist aus Umbrien er ist aus Rom und er
macht Hähnchen am Spieß
er ist ein wirklich netter Kerl da
drüben ist Spanien hier ist Matteo
ich bin Italienerin
sie machen eine wunderbare paille das
sehe ich
meiner Meinung nach ist street food so
fesselnd weil die Risiken begrenzt und
kontrollierbar sind
weil ein Fahrzeug auf Rädern bewegt
werden kann während ein Restaurant
irgendwo festsetzt
und man muss den Bereich für die
potenziellen Kunden überwachen
kann man es sich leisten es
auszuprobieren und wenn es nicht klappt
kann man es am nächsten Tag woanders
versuchen
das Talent von Silvestro und seinen
Jungs ist es den Pizzateig fliegen zu
lassen und jeden Tag mit Leichtigkeit
und Geschick eine einfache und populäre
Speise im kulinarische Kunst zu
verwandeln
[Musik]
beim Schlendern entlang der Stände denke
ich darüber nach warum das street food
in London ein so hohes Niveau erreicht
hat die extrem hohe Qualität das
vielfältige Angebot die größere
Anziehungskraft als die der klassischen
Restaurants und vor allem die große
Publikums Resonanz hier hat die wahre
Entwicklung des street food
stattgefunden vom einfachen straßenessen
zu einem organisierten und erfolgreichen
System es ist wie in China pekinesischer
Geschmack perfekt
[Musik]
die Welt des streetfood ist in ständiger
Bewegung und seine Zukunft scheint auch
in unserem Land vielversprechend zu sein
die Zukunft des street food ist gut denn
die Zukunft ist eigentlich die Gegenwart
wir brauchen bei bestimmten Dingen etwas
mehr Zeit aber ich glaube dass wir einen
Kompromiss mit der Gastronomie finden
müssen
im Grunde müssen wir erst einmal
verstehen dass niemand der Konkurrent
von irgendjemandem ist und Manhattan
gibt es 15 Millionen Menschen
Straßenverkäufer und Restaurants und
alle arbeiten also kann es klappen
ich bin in der Kochkunst Restaurant ist
eindeutig in der Kochkunst Hotel auch
aber auch der Lebensmittelhändler
schließlich machen wir alle denselben
Job und wir sitzen alle im selben Boot
wenn wir nicht miteinander kooperieren
Leute es ist unmöglich weiter zu machen
[Musik]